well we are in for a warm easter weekend
if you plan on hitting the pool
public safety crews reminding everyone
be extra careful
extra vigilant with young children
around water bianca holmen has some
important things to remember well with
kids on spring break and temps in the
90s many of you are probably cleaning
out your backyard pool
but before the first splash here are
some things you want to keep in mind to
keep everyone safe
now drowning is a leading cause of death
in small children
fire officials tell us drowning
accidents are preventable
with the three p's so here they are the
first is patrol an adult should be
watching children at all times in any
type of body of water not just the pool
that includes bathtubs also protect the
pool area
with a barrier or a gate and then
prepare put your child in swimming
lessons
or as an adult take a cpr class it takes
just a few seconds all too often we hear
i had to go and answer the doorbell i
had to answer a phone call i looked away
for just a few moments
these little ones are adventurous and if
those uh in the movies you see the
splashing and the screaming
the reality is these are silent
terrifying
terrifyingly silent events where a child
in just a matter of seconds can slip
below the water
we're told parents should even be more
alert around pools without lifeguards
such as apartment complex or backyard
pools
and unfortunately we have learned that
just this year there have been two
reported
drownings bianca holman 8 news now